all right just logging into my AI
operating system let's see where we are
and what's in the current directory all
right let's navigate to the desktop and
see what's there nothing
we'll now make a testing directory and
navigate to it
let's make into edit a will this work.pi
this file just iterates zero through
nine printing that out as well as
writing to a text file called imagine if
this works let's run this python script
the output at least behaved as expected
but did it create that file too it's
there dare we read it
and now we have text written to an AI
fabricated file using an AI created
python that in a script we also wrote
wrote to a file with that AI Python and
that file is also an AI file in a
directory that AI created with its own
AI file system within an operating
system again that is all a figment of
this AI you think that's error you're
breathing now